viewer discretion is advised Dominus
cops is filmed on location with the
brave strong women of law enforcement
all suspects are innocent until proven
guilty in a court of law
3:15 confirmed suspect is in 302 over
all right so we got two warrants out for
this guy's RSO he's not coming out so
we're gonna have to extract him
3:15 correction suspect is in 301 over
bad girls do corner sit the main
requesting backup
going to perform a tactical reload
[Music]
[Music]
we need medics temp you know I'm gonna
save you we're gonna be fine
[Music]
[Applause]
I hope you all have learned a lot today
just remember if you stay away from
drugs like crack cocaine stay away from
alcohol and stay in school and work
really hard you can do anything a lot of
people told me I wouldn't be able to
make it as a police officer all because
I'm a woman and because I'm weaker and
it's a male-dominated profession but I
persevered and here I am
so you'd be hard-pressed to find anyone
who wouldn't tell you I'm just as good
as any male police officer any questions
yes jack how much can you bench
[Music]
we need backup suspect is on the corner
of MLK Boulevard and East 3rd which way
he's 30 no I mean like where are they at
two miles directly south of your
location
hurry suspect is getting away can you
get me a landmark
oh what a landmark like something I
would recognize if I'm going the way I
am and I see the McDonald's on 3rd dude
do I go right or left
are you serious well landmarks are just
easier than north and south I just need
15 never mind
suspect got away so 9 times our turn if
someone's acting suspicious there
probably sir I need to ask you to pick
up that bottle that bottle over there
won't you don't you pick yourself up
here girl
um no just pick up the bottle no just
you come over here I'm here girl
you fine ass over here um no just can
you pick up the bottle please no just
come over here girl talk over here come
on
no just just the bottle pick it up
we'll talk about the bottle when you
come over here we can play cops and
robbers if you know what I mean girl I'm
a lesbian
[Music]
hey did you like this video it what you
didn't oh you're a cat person well that
makes sense
disregard him and or her /z everyone
else hit the subscribe button and leave
your comment below as to why you like
this video you know what crazy cat you
can get back you couldn't you can
comment below too as to why you don't
like it